- So it's basically Thanksgiving.
So do the holidays, are
they crazy for y'all?
Or do your families get together,
you love it?
- Love it.
- Love.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's like, she's a real,
whatever, like holiday maven.
- Yeah, I'm a holiday maven, yeah.
I enjoy the holidays. I lean in.
- I do, too. Cause it's off time. (laughs)
- Yeah, and I did Martha
Stewart cause I love her,
not because I, you know,
actually made fun of her.
- She's the closest thing to
Martha Stewart that I know.
- [Kelly] Oh my God! It, amazing.
Your impression is amazing.
- Oh, thank you! That's hilarious.
- [Kelly] Do you just break out,
please say at holidays you just
break out in this character.
- I go full in. There's
spreadsheets and yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- What are your family,
like, any traditions?
- We go to Vermont every year,
which is really beautiful,
but cause I had relatives up there.
But well the only the one
holiday that went badly was
the next day, at around
like two in the morning,
I started vomiting and
then I found out that
everyone there had food poisoning.
So like the whole family
had food poisoning.
- Who cooked?
- But we all found out later.
I don't quite remember.
- You don't want to sell anyone out.
- But I just, I might've had
to do with like the stuffing.
I dunno.
- Yeah, it's a cautionary stuffing tale.
- It's a cautionary stuffing tale.
Anyway, that's not a fun story.
- Just a public service
announcement from Rachel.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's... be careful.
- Yeah. That's important. Take
the stuffing out separate.
Do stuff separate.
- Take care of yourself.
Maybe cook your food fully.
- But usually it's fun.
- Yeah. Usually when you're
not having food poisoning.
- My family has had a broken
refrigerator, oven, disposal,
I've had every major appliance
break on Thanksgiving.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So, I, I'm. Yeah. Anyway.
It's a great way to get
to know your neighbors.
- I love that my sister loves to cook,
so I am really great at
helping in doing dishes.